so I'm starting with uh the daily rapid
Arena
warm up for the blitz tournament with
some slower chess
all right playing Gambit
I mean I feel like I should Gambit
against this opponent
Stafford Gambit time
I might be risking my reading
after this game I should check my my
stats
all right I'm gonna insist on the
Stafford Gambit
but no staffers okay we'll have a
symmetrical Italian
H3
yeah so sometimes when white plays H3
early
then
there's prospects of playing H6 G5 G4
but that's only of like castles
yeah in this position there's maybe a
few options
I think I'll start with H6 I'm gonna
stay flexible
and so far it's completely symmetrical
yeah now I'll play G5
I'm pretty sure I had this position
yesterday in the super loots Arena happy
birthday thank you Neil DV
thank you Pablo welcome back
thanks everyone yeah I appreciate all
the kind
words and messages and chats
so Knight H2 okay
Knight H2 is essentially prophylaxis
against
G4
I'm gonna play Rook g8s
I'm making my intention very clear I
want to play G4
open the G file
I'm playing Knight T4 here
or do I play G4 immediately maybe I play
G4 immediately
and I don't mind if uh if takes takes
then
double pawns aren't too bad
okay we have a pretty sharp position to
start
like three moves ago it was maybe the
most boring position one can imagine
just completely symmetrical but now it's
it's heating up
the g-pawn creates some spice in the
position
and there's this lingering tension
between the Pawns
I mean I imagine white will take
and then I can choose whether to take
with Knight or Bishop probably Knights
there's a line like takes takes F3
maybe I can throw in Queen D4 check or
Bishop H3
other lines where I want to play Knight
D4
access C squares
how big is your middle aged crisis
not so big just yet
I feel like I completed the opening on
life
and now I'm entering the middle game
similar to this position like we're
basically done with opening even though
I haven't castled haven't fully
developed my pieces but
trying to make the most of it
I could play this move
yeah taking a non-traditional path here
I want to play G3
to prevent white from playing G3 the
problem is white takes and then
it seems like there'd be a lot of
counter play on a file
so Knight D4 has a benefit of
simply improving the piece
in some cases if white plays G3 maybe I
can hop in
I also free up the C6 Pawn or this the
C7 Pawn to move to C6
maybe eventually this also ideas of
Knight E6
so
still keeping options open
we have G3
yeah let's start with C6
Rook E1
I guess white wants to play this
although Knight F1 will allow this move
so one idea that comes to mind is
B5 Bishop B3 and then A5
now if A4 I take take B5
choices choices
let's start with B5
a nice and aggressive looking
Queen B6 here
looks interesting
it reinforces the pawn
and the event of A4
I think my Kings would be staying in the
center
of these are good but 60s are twice as
good
coming from old Walter I'm looking for
an
all right so Knight F6 here
looks pretty good
or a knight F3 I should say I have three
takes takes yeah let's just go for it
I don't think it's good for white to
take
even though this Knight is like so
passive it wants to trade off
I've opened the G file and then there's
ideas of like C4 and Rook G3 eventually
but if King
actually what does white do here
King G2 okay wait a minute King G2 I
take the Rook
as it might already be winning for for
black
oh Slowpoke asking have you played spell
chess
yeah I saw the the new variants I saw
like one video on it but
I haven't played it on chess.com
but I played another version of it
um
there were a couple
couple of viewers slash mods in my chat
that
like programmed spell chess maybe a year
or two ago
and I played it on their website
so I wonder if they had some involvement
with
making a come to chess.com
uh okay C4
but this isn't so simple
I want to play C4 but then Queen
takes F3
and then that hits a knight
yeah
I thought I would be winning something
but maybe not
I mean there's also the idea of taking
on G3 immediately take and then this
because of this it's made instantly if
this is Queen F2 made instantly if King
H1 Queen F2
[Music]
I guess there's Rook
No rookie two I guess I was Rook G1
thank you
let's go wait I got the focus here okay
take take and then C4
King H1 Queen F2 Rook G1 Knight G4
looks winning so the only thing I'm not
sure about is D4
and I take
I'll be down a rook but both the pieces
are attacked
go take take
I mean I should just play Bishop G4
I'll analyze after if if Rook G3 was
playable
I I couldn't make the line work after C4
D4
I appreciate all the good vibes
um unfortunately I'm probably gonna have
to
uh just not look at chat for the
remainder of this game getting along
time the position is really nice though
uh's Pawn is attacked
so do I go for this
maybe I do
ideas to take on G3 and play C4
or play C4 and then take on G3
realizing I could probably throw in this
move too
try and trap the bishop
yeah there's some nice x-ray vision with
a rook align with a king and my queen of
line with the King
so this construction it looks stable but
it's not the most stable
if the king moves away then F2 becomes
more of a Target then the Queen's tied
down
in some cases
so opponent taking time
I guess if I want to be extra solid I
could play Rook G6
just defend
maybe even like put the king over put
the Rook over
put all the pieces on the king side
because it's hard for white to do much
like the structure
essentially restricts the Knight and
Bishop
let's go for A5 here
so if Queen takes H6 I play C4 hitting
this but more importantly hitting
F2 and threatening mate
yeah I guess now Rook G6
although there is this move first
kind of like that
giving white the option of taking
because there's no need to prevent a
move which isn't good for the opponent
and I'm pinning this Pawn so C4
maybe strikes more of a punch
okay so I'm pretty sure white took the
baits
now I play this
and the queen can't really generate much
counter play
like all these squares are controlled in
my territory
I guess maybe there's this move
but Queen H7 still gets mated toggy
gifting 10. thank you taggy
448 total gifted Subs
engine with a prime sub
yeah if you were a gift to the sub say
thank you
I'm super super generous
ticking wow so if I take I lose my queen
very fancy I could take with the Rook
I could just move the queen too
I'm just trying to make sure I'm not
blundering anything
um
a take with a rook take
and first I'll take my time before
taking any pieces
I'm calculating a funny line Queen C5
so first of all if Knight C7 King D7
then I get stuck if Knight here the
funny line is takes takes and then Rook
D6
and the Queen's just trapped
I think
because I I control these squares
control these squares
control this Square these squares these
squares are covered
pawns defended
meanwhile yeah Knights attack the pawns
attacked twice F7 is still undefended
be too could hang maybe I Queen in some
lines
how messy can I make the board
I highlight every square root before the
opponent moves
did I do it oh D3 E2
H2 E8
t7
I think I did a G8
every oh A1
G4
every time I think I highlight every
Square I see a new Square E4 F3
okay
it was probably not the best thing to do
while the opponent was deliberating
off
I had to make some artwork though
okay so the Knight is actually trying to
survive
but if I play this
it should be trapped
ooh
wait can I trap the queen
Rook h8 Network
I should just take
triple Pawns
one capture away from quadruple Pawns
quadruple pawns are probably not
happening here though
ooh
okay so let's play this
I'm trying to trap the queen so Queen H7
probably King E7
and now Knight F6 looks pretty
Unstoppable
oh now it's white with triple Pawns
yeah this queen has gone a bit too far
okay that was actually a cool game
um
I'm actually curious if this is any sort
of opening Theory
it has been reached in Master Level play
engine says oh engine says like Block's
already equalized
92 is the only move to not be worse
after Rook G8
yeah it seems difficult for white to
play actually
look what happened in the game
I do want to check the line
I was analyzing with Rook G3
so I played Bishop G4
engine likes Rook G3
I just couldn't figure this out take
here and then D4
and then take and then take
like I saw these lines but
I was scared that my knight is hanging
in the end
but the engine is just Fearless engine
just says take the pawn attack The Rook
and so funny to have Five Pawns
on these three files
yeah I guess the bishop is just trapped
and my king is relatively safe
I see the question from zadry
yeah unfortunately the the company that
I work with for the merch
um the larger mugs have been out of
stock for a while and it's a bit out of
my control so
I'm not sure when they'll be back but
I'm pretty sure the the 12 ounce mugs
are still in stock speaking of I should
make um a coupon code for today
um maybe I'll I'll do it uh between
games or after the tournament
okay uh let's play E4 oh opponent
berserking okay we'll have a Blitz game
in the rapid tournament
I'll play D4 we'll have a Smith Mora
and C3
do you have any birthday plans
my plans are to Gambit and then attack
and then hopefully checkmate
but first have to develop
okay Bishop C4
ah okay my opponent's playing the
actually one of the best lines
this is what I would like to play but I
don't think Bishop takes C3 is the best
move
I'll play E5
restricting the d-pawn for movement
now maybe bishop G5 maybe rookie won
first
just reinforcing the pawn
so if Knight G6 I I defend and then I'll
push the H Pawn
if B6 I might have a
a very devious idea
okay I want this degree gift but box not
allowing it
let's still play Queen E2 probably go
for this
set up the mating idea
there is a common principle
when you're white and you have a Pawn on
E5 in the middle game
in most cases you should attack on the
the king side
so that's what I'm trying to do here
and this box is going to defend like H5
Knight f8 defending each seven
so black plays H5 himself
Wow Let's Play Bishop A3
so now the d-pawn moves I'm going to
take on D6 and
the bishop will support the pawn
if the d-pawn doesn't move I play Bishop
D6 anyway
and then that looks like full domination
like Bishop D6 Knight G5
no mercy here
probably threatening to take on F7
take take
yeah light has a lot more attackers and
black has Defenders on the king side
even ideas like G4 H5
this opening worked out pretty well
Barrow says hope your 20s gamut opening
got you a better 30s middle game
yeah not sure how much I sacrificed in
my 20s
I did sacrifice a lot of a lot of Pawns
decent amount of Queens
and throughout my 20s I played well over
a thousand Stafford gambits
thank you Tuesday gin gifting five
hi chat hello Fox YouTube videos a lot
got a good chuckle from stockfish
that was probably the buggiest I've ever
seen leechas
but to be fair I I wasn't really using
the feature correctly I was just
using it very impatiently
but it was so funny to like see leeches
make a piece like disappear and then
reappear and then yeah it looked like
soccer hung the king even though
like the server didn't register the move
okay I guess I still have to work for
this I'm
up the exchange
though black is trying to hold on
this is now actually kind of a threat
so let's play this
okay I should bring my king in
oh I miss Bishops he said or Brook takes
C6
ah
yeah I should have listened to Ben
Feingold never play off three
especially when there's a free Bishop
okay this will just take a little bit
longer why is there a mosquito
I have my trusty blindfold mosquito
whacker
actually I'm not sure if that was a
mosquito or like a large gnat
ah
okay
uh
it's not trying to like attack me it
keeps flying around
what to do
trying to catch the mosquito and my
opponent's king
which one can I catch first
is there an opening called the mosquito
I feel like there is
okay this is actually going to be quite
nice
H6 is coming
my openings
I'll check after this game
at least Kings can't fly yeah that would
be
much harder to catch a king if it could
just fly off the board
enter the third dimension
man this is still a struggle
King F7 defends the pawn but then okay I
have Rook H6
making progress
if King G7 I'll take with this Rook
oh Joe did not realize they were subbed
yeah there was some gifting earlier so
say thank you to whoever gifted you
okay
I didn't catch the mosquito but I call
Vox King
um
mosquito
wow the mosquito Gambit it's a variation
of the England
D4 E5 Queen H4
wow
I feel like I've seen this once before
and then forgot about it
have I ever played this opening Explorer
I've never played this
if I encounter D4 next game
maybe I'll try this it looks terrible
Knight of three best move Queen d8
when two people on leechas play
Queen H5 looks reasonable
okay
anyway I'm gonna be right back I'm gonna
find some bug spray and also try and
make this merch coupon code so BRB and
stay tuned for maybe a mosquito Gambit
foreign
happy birthday birthday cake
okay
uh where is the tournament here we go
all right I'm back
I just used a little bit of this just to
make sure I don't get bin
your chair just got 15
hey Miguel
things for the fifteen dollars
happy birthday I appreciate that
I replayed the donation
that would be like a weird infinite
money Loop if I could just replay keep
replaying the donation
but uh okay we have a philodor
I'll play D4
D4 or maybe I'll play C3
happy birthday treat this like a
ponziani to catch you live again
oh thank you
honor kicks
sorry if the TTS is a little bit low
just raised it a little bit
okay Asics is um
basically giving me a free Tempo maybe
black was scared of this and this
let's play this
okay I have this move now
so I'm kind of abandoning the e-pawn
and the Knight
but this looks pretty problematic for
black
and this is one of the benefits of C3
early
Queen can come and
combine well with the bishop and attack
by b-pong
oh and also yeah the the birthday coupon
code should be working for the merch
okay
hey it's I love pizza and chicken
okay I'm just getting this link ah
where's my thing
okay let's take this thing
okay merge command updated
all right now yeah
it's a matter of trying to
get more things to attack the king
so if takes I take with the Knight
the only thing I have to watch out for
like takes takes
King here there could be like some
eventual Queen D1 ideas
but not quite
I play H3
[Music]
I I feel very spoiled for Choice here
I think I'll play H3 though
simply attacking the bishop
and if the bishop takes I can throw in
this check
and force akin to C6
yeah Queen E6
Queen D5
although do I want to play Queen D5 or
just take the bishop right away
probably Queen D5 first
because then The Rook will be hanging
yeah maybe black has some other options
there
Knight C5 was a playable move maybe at
some point
but now yeah the Knight and the Rook are
both attacked
Bishop E3 on the horizon
I do allow Knight D3
Knight D3 King D1 should be okay
actually Knight F2 in that line but
okay it's not happening
I'll play Bishop E3
yeah I mean positions like this are
they're completely winning but
it's still a fun kind of mental exercise
to figure out
the most efficient way to checkmates
um the opponent making my life a bit
easier
there's two legal moves here
okay resigning was a another legal
option
um okay that worked out nicely Queen B3
how many games have occurred in this
position
uh Bishop
Bishop H5 most common
wait I'm really surprised that black
score is so much better
how does black Score so much better here
Queen B7
maybe bug just treats us as a Gambit I
mean the engine says White's winning
it's just a low sample size of games
that's crazy that white I would have
expected white to score at least 70
after Queen B3
ah D5 also playable
because if takes then there's Bishop F7
okay
all right moving back to the tournament
played three games so far
question about posting a video link
uh yeah generally links just get deleted
By Night parts
but you can whisper me a video link
welcome back to Gary
thank you Gary
Shiloh tagari
yeah there's no way for me to actually
um
easily like disable the
nightbot restrictions
okay let's play
I mean I haven't had a true Stafford yet
so
let's go for this
we had the one uh symmetrical Italian
which actually led to a very short
position
[Music]
I I feel a sense of nostalgia there
hey it's I love pizza and chicken happy
birthday getting merch
yeah we do have the coupon code birthday
for much today
okay
wait what is this line D4 let's play D5
there's a line where Bishop like the
super sharp line Bishop C5 Bishop C4
Knight F2 Bishop F7 which
I don't really want to go into
um
can I
I want to play this move but takes takes
takes takes
Bishop F5 looks playable
Queen B6 actually looks playable
I think I'll play Queen B6
this feels like a reverse version of
last game
where I I move my C Pawn early I'm
bringing my queen out hitting this
not really double attacking but
I'm making it so if the bishop develops
and B2 is hanging
also thank you fathers
gifting to lip to neck green
I was thinking about playing this bishop
G4 take take but then Queen C8
is a small issue
maybe just Bishop E7
or Bishop C Bishop C5 C3
Castle
[Music]
let's go for this
a bit more aggressive
I have this move there's E6 take take
looks pretty good
B4
played Super quickly
can I I can't quite win a pawn
the B4 is actually a good move
if I take the queen will take
[Music]
maybe I just moved back my favorite
Grand Master Ben Feingold don't get
impersonated by people who aren't Grand
Masters ah the truth hurts
also ridiculous
[Music]
happy birthday oh thank you
Captain swing
okay I gotta Focus here a little bit
uh
it's not super simple
I think I'll play I'll play Knight F6
I'm gonna lose the pawn it's attacked
twice and pinned
unless is there some
some trickery C5 doesn't really work
the Alpine F6
and then if takes I just take Queen
takes and then Rook F7
okay let's play this
yeah my opponent's played a very good
game so far for the rating
still feels like I'm
I'm solid
might end up trading very soon
have an idea to go for this and then
this
eventually gets some King side attack
F4
could start with rookie Eights
I could on passant to the don't really
want to open that file for white
let's start with this
so I'm threatening some discoveries
against the queen
mainly Bishop C5 or Bishop takes B4
on persona's first
it's only forced in some small
communities on the internet
oh
opponents showing no fear
no fear is sometimes a a good thing but
sometimes it's a bad thing
but I'm actually winning anything like
Bishop C5 Queen H3
I guess takes takes
we have some like almost trapezoid
rhombus shape
Knight G4
Queen goes off here here
yeah it's probably better for me just to
take the pawn
as much as I want to play Bishop C5
what about take take and Knight D5
I lose a seven
yeah okay let's just take the pawn
happy birthday thank you a Stony play
an order tile
happy 17 months and 14 months happy
birthday Eric
oh I could have played Bishop C5 and
duck H3
but then my opponent could move the
queen and put the duck on D4
If This Were duck chess
yeah in Dutchess I don't think I would
have any obvious tactic there
because the opponent could also put the
duck on E7 potentially
but there's no duck to block White's
problems here
yeah let's move back
I am giving back the A7 Pawn
we'll see if white wants to take it
Okay so
Knight G5
maybe I should just play King h8 I could
also play B5
I could also continue to overthink
things
let's play B5
just expand the tempo
or maybe A5
or maybe now 95
. I like this better
because the Queen's no longer attacking
the pawn
now I can play this
the Knight is pinned
not easy for white to exploit if C4 I
take it
um
play this move
even
uh how to do this
not easy to defend the pawn
I could take on F4
yeah for some reason I was looking at
defense rather than offense
ooh
so I take the Rook I got needed very
tricky
I could take the knights
just probably the best move
just making sure I'm not missing
anything
because if Rook takes it looks scary but
I take the bishop with check and then
recapture
okay
are we gonna see Queen B8
the queen bee that I would play Rook e8s
with check so there's no Queen takes E8
okay
um yeah my opponent actually played very
well for the rating I may have been
worse at some point in that game
yeah like after a bishop E7
so I was supposed to take on D4
but now that five would have been really
strong hitting this maybe setting up
Queen g42
yeah good opening for my opponent
so this position Bishop E7 best move or
Knight A6 Bishop v7s probably most
natural though
okay
so again for anyone just joining we're
doing a viewer Arena starting in
just over an hour and 15 minutes
feel free to use a join command
it'll be a blitz tournament
but for the time being I'm playing the
daily
rapid Arena
how are the standings I have 13
tournament points
leader has 37. might be hard to win the
tournament
it was whoosh saw the most recent video
probably
against Boston Mike
all right moving on
um
I played E4 let's play Knight of three
Let's uh mix up the opening a little bit
we have C5 so I could go into Sicilian
I think I'll play uh this tricky move
over there E3
which could lead into like reverse nimso
or reverse Queens Indian
welcome back Irene
thanks so much
Bishop yeah Bishop B2 this is
exactly reverse Queen's Indian
now yeah Asics prevents Bishop B5 which
is very typical move
but I can play C4 here
D4 is pretty restricted
now I think I'll take and
play D4
and the basic strategy for why this is a
trade d-pawn for C Pawn
and then leave lock
with isolate Queen's Pawn
but I'm not in any Rush
essentially I'm waiting for the bishop
to move and then I'll take on Z5
wow Bishop E4 happy birthday
thank you Bill zidab welcome back
trying to process this move I think I
just keep developing reinforce the night
okay black
spending a lot of time
so I'll keep improving
and now I am threatening to just take
and win the pawn
welcome back to Joe broon
thanks so much Joe
I have not tried spellchess on chess.com
I have been getting a lot of questions
if I have time maybe later maybe
sometime this coming week
okay let's take the Knight
so some transformation here
I like the idea of f4 not only
reinforcing the pawn but threatening to
trap that Bishop
yeah we're gonna have some fun here
abyssable retreats
and now it's a question
oh what to do I have this move
I think E6 is the type of move I just
play in
enjoy whatever happens if takes takes
I actually have takes I could throw in
this first
hmm
I play E4 here
and go over E4
the idea is to remove this pawn and open
the diagonal so my Bishop can come to C4
oh
okay so now I have Bishop H5 check
I could start with E5 too
this is probably where I slow down and
calculate a little bit
I like the prospect of E5 though
so I simply hit the knights
and now I can throw in this
oh there's a funny line
Bishop H5 King E7 take take F6 take take
and it's mate
happy birthday Eric let's do it got to
lift those rocks
oh yeah it's time to Rook lift bro
oh thank you Matt
oh getting the uh The Rook lift tank top
nice
haven't worn that one in a while on
stream
okay what to do here
just looking for
looking for a reasonable approach maybe
this move
because there's a cool idea if Bishop
takes I can take on D5 with a knight
and a pawn takes I win the bishop if
Queen takes
I would I thought I had this move but
I'm realizing there was Bishop E4
but we're not getting getting that
may have been based on a small oversight
there
okay G6 I'll throw in this
and I'm less interested in winning this
pawn and more interested in winning this
Pawn
I'd be nice for ample songs
bullied on passant
not quite possible
oh welcome back test nabe ignore
happy22
22 months of me not really ignoring you
okay so freeing up the other Bishop
hitting the Rook
um
okay
seems like mate is
I mean it feels like Nate should be
forced here somehow
I'll just keep giving checks
check
just kidding Checkmate okay
uh that was a fun game
it started with um a pretty like solid
positional line reverse Queen's Indian
but happy in the middle game I just had
better development and then I think once
I got the pawn to E5 and played F4 it
was
uh it was all the fun for lights
thank you D hazy
okay
playing powerful
ah powerful uh
like full of power
products in your store
oh yeah I have to um
have to design something
put together some design ideas
I am due for some new uh
some new designs in the merch store
okay I'm playing a scandi knight of six
candy
this is definitely not
a challenging line
because white basically just gave me the
whole Center
and I think the best way to play this is
the castle Queen side and go for this E5
idea been a while since I've tuned in
welcome back Pocky penguin
happy nine months
oh I forgot about the mosquito
but I don't think I've encountered D4
yet on move one
Okay so
first question is can I win a pawn
like take take take
no because take on G4
could play H5
I mean C4 might be coming so
I could consider taking and then taking
but
I'm not super fond of giving away the
bishop pair
and what about E5
E5 C4
not super sure how to proceed here
and objectively this might be the best
approach just to take the pawn
is there anything to be afraid of like
take take take
we could get some end game
I've double pawns but I'll be up a pawn
take take take
queenie295.
Yeah the more I'm looking at this the
more it seems like I should just go for
this line
upon is a pawn
I'm not even getting double pawns
because yeah if it takes I take the
queen first
uh Queen takes I take with Knight
so I guess what's happening after Queen
E2
Queen e295
hitting the bishop
Bishop E4
maybe Queen C4 in that position
[Music]
it looks playable let's go for it
okay it's possible why it has some
compensation here
maybe I should have
been a little bit more careful
95.
I'm thinking Bishop E4 just E6
and then get the bishop developed
wow
okay so now I could take with check
which I should probably just do
and then Queen D5
so we're trading a lot
the one downside here is White House the
connected Rooks
I'm still a bit underdeveloped on the
king side
but I'm offering the queen trade
and I don't
don't want to give away any initiative
five flag in the check hitting the queen
here then could probably play six
hey it's John Bartholomew
thank you John Bartholomew
I appreciate the rain
if you're just joining hey uh if you're
just joining I play the scandi uh
hashtag teamscandy in honor of John
trying to make Jon proud opponent just
made Luft
I think I'll go for E5 now
it's finally time to develop my king
cyan
and if Rook D1 I'm happy to take and get
two Rooks for the queen
if C4
probably happy to trade Queens
if Queen C2 I play this
try and be solid
isn't John's birthday coming up in like
a few days
or am I mistaken
maybe it's Ben feingold's birthday it's
like the sixth
but I'm trying to remember
like some strong players born in
September
okay the Rooks attacked I want to
activate the Rook but I want to lose a
rook
so as I play Rook
at Rook D7 looks solid
oh John's birthday is September 5th oh
wow
happy early birthday
okay
I could play Bishop D4 here
like Bishop D4 and then this move
should be three calculating this this
this
and then this
I mean there's options
I think I'll go for that
also big thanks to everyone like dming
me
um
I've been getting like a lot of DMS with
stream my watch keeps buzzing so
I appreciate those people
who are sending the DMS but
apologies I can't respond right away
I have to try and convert this position
first
I do actually have a trivia question
um which sadly I'm not the answer to
the question is who is the strongest
chess player
born on this day
I'm curious if anyone knows the answer
bonus points if you name the top two
strongest players born on this day
it's not me
maybe I'm within like top 10
born on September 3rd
but there's there's at least a couple
Grand Masters that I'm aware of
it's not Magnus and Hikaru good try
though
all right how to do this
opponents resisting I think I'll play A4
it's um
a classic
positional move
fixing the pawn on the dark Square
now I'll play C5
I just want to use the B file Hillary
Duff wait Hillary Duff is born today
or maybe on this day like years ago
I see one right answer in the chat
now
wait a minute
now let's take the pawn because if Pawn
takes I can start pushing
if Bishop takes
if I want to be really fancy I could
take and push and
that's probably winning
but I can also play C5 there
[Music]
is go
okay do I want to be fancy take the
bishop push the pawn
that's probably the cleanest approach
there there
but C5 is also like quite clean
let's play C5
because I have just such a dominant
Bishop
my um
what do we call this wooden Shield
and then Rook B3 is coming next
the only way for white to try and save
the pawn is Bishop here Rook B3 Bishop
C1
but that walks into Rook B1
wait is it Tanya's birthday today
a lot of people are saying Tani
oh it's his birthday today I didn't know
that
what's his feet I rating
is he higher than me
no I still have a few points on him
but probably not for long
yeah so the strongest player who's born
on September 3rd is Arjun aragaisi
as far as I know
unless there is someone above him and
I'm missing
I'm pretty sure also uh Grandmaster
Alexander onishook
who uh actually used to coach me at like
various chess camps
what prize do I get for guessing it
I could give you a sub can I gift a sub
on my own channel
give subscription go to checkout Payment
Processing
hey I gifted you a sub
happy uh happy birthday to you
probably belated birthday
okay
um that was a feel-good game
stemming from a scandi
got the John Bartholomew raid this game
I will say that I wasn't entirely
confident if white were to play Bishop
E4 here
because white has a bishop pair like
some scary moves are maybe coming
engine says
I was gonna play E6
engine says it's close to equal
maybe white has compensation wait Polo
guyevsky
all these players who
whose birthdays I have not looked up
polygrofsky was born November 20th
according to Google
but maybe not according to chat GPT
oh God zinisco
paid it forward and gifted to tonsenkos
appreciate that
yeah if I keep gifting subs and it's
it's infinite money
probably infinite money for twitch and
not for me
okay so we move on
um if I encounter D4 then maybe I'll try
this mosquito Gambit which
has plus four for the opponent
so depending on my opponent too see what
happens
wait what oh okay I'm white so
let's keep mixing it up
I'll play
I'll play this
and let's play
what is my opponent doing let's play
this
man they're pre-moving
what are the odds
okay they didn't pre-move
I was trying to catch them but
that's okay we'll treat this as a
candidate
Knight D7
that's probably not the best opening
though
I played G4
oh this is a bad decision
a G4
let's play D4
okay just a small gamut
I think I'll play this
combine it with Rook D1
and then Queen H4
looks interesting
Queen B6 was a good move
actually I've really misplayed this
opening
I think I have to go into damage control
mode
like Bishop C1
yeah I can't afford to play B3
or can I B3 Queen B4
maybe it's playable actually B3 idea
Knight A4 and Bishop D2
it looks so wrong though
but generally like if you don't see
anything wrong with something you should
just go for it
if there is something wrong with this
I'll learn a lesson
and now Bishop D2
Queen H5
because I have this move
because my opponent just wants to trade
queens and beat up upon
if Queen G4 maybe Queen C7
in the meantime I want to play Bishop E2
not the happiest move
what about Knight D4
thank you xanthavax gifting five
I'm really regretting the opening that I
chose
oh what to do
94 is coming take take Knight G5
[Music]
yeah let's go for that
Knight H5
I was banking on Queen
C7
it looks scary but
I might as well do it
wow
now I'll probably Castle
man I have to be really really careful
here
what about Knight H5
all right Knight H4
Knight H4 Queen moves
and then Castle
it's a bit awkward for both of us
if I Castle First Take take Bishop E5
oh Bisbee 5 traps a queen wow
I think I have to play this
man super risky play
and G3
about taking the Knight
and G3 here
this looks so wrong though
but I really don't see too many other
options
so I'm still down the pawn bishop G4
happens
so I have this move
foreign
I'm trying to process everything
there there
it's getting real messy
I mean the queen is almost trapped for
black
like both our Queens are almost trapped
so I have this move now
attacking the queen
these moves seem scary but my Knights
are covering both squares
so my Bishop would be pinned in the vent
of the night move
oh no
okay I've completely overlooked Knight
D3 and queen digs E2 checkmates opponent
misses it though
an iPhone's moving a little bit too
quickly
and now maybe now maybe I just taken
castle and then
avoid getting needed
F4 is also interesting though
F4 take
a four take take image no I'm not
traveling the queen
but am I winning material
I'm not confident in my calculations
here I think I'll go for this
take
feels like the
like the G pawns almost overworked but
my Bishop supports F4 as well so if
takes I take with Bishop and if takes
the plan is to take here
hitting the queen and if Queen takes we
trade Queens I take the bishop I'll be
up a minor piece
for two Pawns
foreign
I could take with Queen too but probably
better to take with a pawn
it's very important I have a rook here
preventing Queen F1 checkmate
and now we trade queens and
yeah I'm up at night for two Pawns
threatening this and this
I really dodged a bullet there though
like that could have been easily winning
now this will still take a bit of work
because I have
um not the most amount of time
but the position is looking good
okay let's go back
maybe like
yeah I think the goal
the goal should just be to simplify
trade off the Rooks
and black either has to trade or lose
control over the D file
if Bishop D6 I have Knight B7
to trade further
yeah after the game I can show the
the missed win in more detail
okay here
um
let's play C5
and trade trade
okay plenty of time
have you ever seen a trumpeter swan
I I don't really know how to distinguish
between different types of swans
so that might be hard to answer
okay still have a nice bind maybe
threatening this
and then the Knight can reposition
I think the goal is to create some
mating that with uh
The Rook Bishop in Knights
the king is now forced back to the back
rink
if Knight F6 I take and I'll be
threatening mating one
uh enough seven coming
start with check
and then this
black is very close to forcing stalemate
but the pawn can move so Rook F2 doesn't
quite work
Rook H7
uh
I guess I'll just meet with bishop and
Knight
if fairuzia can do it
I should be able to figure it out
oops what did I do
why am I struggling
happy birthday oh thank you
okay this is the fanciest way to do it
Bishop B2
the end game fee in cattle
okay
not my proudest game I mean my opponent
really like punished me after this E5
move when I played E5 I thought it was
like a cool gamut idea but
appreciate that
yeah huge thanks to everyone for all the
like super generous support and all the
birthday wishes
people getting merch
gifted subs and Jonas oh and also some
people doing research on Grand Masters
born this day
so
Anisha sargassian
Rashad babayov
ni
some some names I haven't heard of
actually
an Arjun Erica you see
yeah I wanted to share uh I'll probably
end up posting this photo on Twitter
this is a photo uh that Irene sukhandar
actually took last year
at the Abu Dhabi Masters for your
birthday
um I meant to tweet this out last year
on September 3rd but I forgot so
hopefully I can
tweet it out this year
thank you Gary
oh thanks so much Gary
put that towards the pizza fund
okay
um
yeah let me just show
yeah it could have been really bad
wait it was force made in three
ah because I have two hangs yeah I
missed Knight T3 like when I played
Knight C5 I just assumed I'm I'm
controlling D3 but
Queenie 2 is a May threat
and if King F1 I could run but I can't
hide because Queen takes off two mates
so the game could have ended pretty
abruptly
but hey I made no no mistakes and no
inaccuracies
almost a perfect game on my part right
opponent also made no mistakes
really appreciate that
oh is tweet no longer
a thing
yeah it's gonna take me a long time to
adjust
okay
anyway moving on
playing
jelly peppermints
what to play I haven't played like a
true ponziani yet
but we'll have a ponziani
Bishop C5 Bishop C5 is like a kind of
ironic move because
it looks like it's fighting for D4 but
it actually makes Pawn D4 stronger
because black loses time having to move
the bishop again
I have a similar position a few days ago
in the monthly classical Arena
my opponent had played takes and then D5
so here I think a similar strategy
applies that I can just grab space
with Pawn E5
I do allow the bishop to come in but
I'm not too scared of that
but there are some options here
could consider Bishop B5 like all these
Bishop moves are possible
Queen B3 is maybe possible
Bishop E3
oh no my Tempe
yeah that's probably what my opponent is
saying
lost a tempo
I'm taking time here because I'm just
trying to figure out like the best way
to
develop like I know box probably gonna
go for 97 next move
and there's some idea of taking and
trying to win D4
so I could play Bishop E3
maybe not a bad idea
just reinforced D4
staying flexible where to put this
bishop and like going forward as we
finish the opening and approach the
middle game
I'm just gonna try and like keep
optimizing the pieces make use of the
space advantage
but the Rook on C1
oh do I have a tactic here Bishop takes
H7
I'll admit that
like when I play Bishop D3 I didn't see
the fact that I'm potentially setting up
this tactic
and so sorry the thing I should have
seen coming but
it looks to be working
it's a different type of Greek gift
though because The Bishop's here so the
point is after takes Knight G5 the king
defends a bishop
I would have a G4 trapping the bishop if
the king were here
but in this case
I went back the piece so I want a pawn
and I'm
basically mating here
like how does black not get mated
maybe rookie Gates
but then I'll have some fun
I'll be winning the queen
check
anything better check
I don't see Force mates but Knight E6 is
pretty devastating
I really want to take
take check Knight of five though
okay I'll take the queen
and then F4
did I miss Maiden one
someone says
made in one question mark
Queen h8 would have allowed Knight g8s
and then then black is preventing Knight
E6
but I'm just curious if I had anything
stronger
Queen H5 may be also possible
it doesn't feel good game though like
opponent made kind of a
it's a classic amateur mistake in the
panziani
playing Bishop C5
but then made a very clear tackle
mistake with castling
okay back to tournament
top ten
still pretty far away from first though
okay keeping keeping things clean
I should have lost that previous game
the opponent had made in three
so I just want to check my rapid stats
I'm on a 25 game win streak
hopefully I don't jinx myself
let's play a serious opening
let's play
um a non-staffer Gambit
I'll play The Accelerated dragon
and we have the the Marazzi which is one
of the most trendy things to do against
accelerated dragon
I'll play this move order with Knight F6
Knight F6 in Bishop G7 they look similar
but they lead to slightly different
lines
because now I can play D6 and if Bishop
E3 I play Knight G4
so this is the main line now I take
before the bishop can take back
and now Castle Queen Z1
don't think Queen D1 is a most common
move
so we have a very standard position for
Marazzi binds
and I'm not booked up here but I do know
some general plans
one plan is to just push the a pawn
which I think I'll go for
like there's cases sometimes that goes
for A6 B5
but in this case
oh I guess A4 is prevented or is it
now A4 take I can take on e4
yeah let's still go for this
this is multi-purpose like I'm trying to
weaken the diagonal for white
I'm also freeing open uh A5 Square for
the queen
but A3 looks really nice here
like there's a typical idea of takes I
can take on e4 as on the knights
undefended and pinned
so The Rook
so we have Queen B3
wow
Queen B3 Queen A5
I could start by taking and then light
structure is kind of
fractured a little bit happy birthday
Eric oh thank you mole SG
so I'm considering taking Queen A5 or
Knight E7 I think these are the top
three candidate moves also Bishop E6
and one thing I like about this is I
keep the tension
and if takes I still have this idea
hey it's Phoebe V how do I pronounce the
name vidi right
Phoebe wit thanks for the raid I
appreciate it
if you're just joining I'm trying to
figure out what to do in this position
[Music]
Queen A5
Pawn takes Pawn Knight takes E4
it gets messy
Rook takes takes looks good though
it's one of these positions like there's
a lot of good looking moves I just have
to not overthink things
not burn all my time on a single move
so Bishop D2 now I can take
because I like the I like the x-ray
vision now
maybe Knight D7
and there's also this x-ray vision so
it could get messy
I'm considering Queen H5
Bishop E6 comes to mind
okay I'm gonna start with Knight D7 it's
a very typical move in the the dragon
and accelerated dragon
to just unleash the
the bishop
which supposedly breathes fire along the
long diagonal
and then the Knight can come to C5 and
apply pressure
there might be ideas of putting the
queen on E5 and then having the battery
but so far it seems like a decent
opening success
oh Phoebe's birthday is a week from
today oh happy early birthday to Phoebe
so September 10th I assume
I'll have to try and remember to send a
raid if you stream on that day
okay so Rook ab1
um Bishop D4
Knight C5
yeah let's start with Knight C5
and this is a huge focal point
imagine Bishop C2
although Bishop C2 obstructs the queen
from defending the bishop and now
probably Bishop
E6
attacking the Now undefended Pawn
like white wants to considered night
moves to attack my queen like leaving
both Queens hanging
but the problem with the night moves is
The Bishop's not defended so basically
any night move I just take the bishop
and this is really the dream like from
the
position where I played A5 A4
like this is the best I can ask for like
both Bishops Queen and Rook Knight
they're all applying pressure to the
weak points in White's position
but it's not every day right it's not
every game that you can get this against
uh the Marazzi bind like sometimes it's
white who's
just squeezing black
yeah I didn't want to take on C3 and win
the A2 Pawn maybe it was playable but
um it's definitely not worth giving away
the bishop
so now can I take on C4
some things to calculate
happy birthday
thank you quarantine chess noob
so I'm calculating takes
Knight D5 and then I take back
I think it's all fine for black
and the pawn is upon
the knight's so good here like defending
B7 to
white goes for this
so now it's just very confusing because
my Queen's attacked white swings
attacked e7's attacked which would come
with check
at first I was thinking I just take the
queen but I think I'd take the Knight
first
because I don't want 97 to come
takes text takes yeah we're going to be
trading a lot
and I think once the dust settles
I might be winning A2 in the end
so after all the takes takes takes I
think black will be up two Pawns
there's not too many ways for white to
avoid the queen trade
I see there's a comment you can't take
the knights
well now yeah I can't take something
that's already off the board
he takes takes takes and after takes
takes
that worked out nicely
we can check with engine
um but that was like a really kind of
feel good game from
the black side of a Marazzi bind
and it's a four
yeah so Queen A5
Knight G4 I did not consider it's a cool
move though
okay yeah it seemed pretty clean
hey perfect game
or almost perfect 97 accuracy
less blunders compared to some of my
previous games
okay
moving on
foreign
have you played pickleball
I haven't
I was close to playing once
fellow fellow streamer Katie learns uh
visited town
uh what a couple of months ago
and we were very close to playing
pickleball but we ended up just playing
tennis
but I'd like to try someday
C3
confusing move this is a Saragosa
opening
what do I do against this move
if I ever probably D5
we'll probably transpose into some kind
of
Kali or reverse slav kapon's going for
maybe a reverse check periods
I wonder if
F6 could make some sense
but Knight C6 makes more sense
develop
okay so we're basically getting a
reverse periods
and then it's a question which setup I
want to choose
I mean maybe I'll go for F6 and like
this kind of English attack setup
it's something I play from the white
side usually when I'm white it comes
from like a job of London move order
so I'm essentially down to Tempo but
maybe getting some active play I could
Castle here
castling does seem risky because
um I'm basically walking into White's
potential attack but
I don't really see how white causes any
like big issues
because usually it's a B Pawn that wants
to move and the B Pawn is blocked by the
queen
I should note that D4 maybe looked
attractive but
like I could just play C4
I don't want to open the diagonal for
white
so what to do
Bishop here looks attractive
starting my own attack
and the classic idea is H5 H4 take take
eventually checkmate
am I scared of this 80 Pawn
maybe a little bit
like I'm debating whether to allow E6
or just
ignore it or
yeah basically ignore it and allow it
or prevent it
I mean A6 B6 looks like I'm
a bit weak but
I don't see any huge Danger
worst case I move the Knight back and
hunker down
so I think I'll go for this
it's interesting though it's getting
spicy
yeah I I do enjoy like a lot of sports
that involve
rackets or paddles and a net
like the solo
a lot of solo sports like Ping Pong
tennis
like volleyball too
okay probably 97 to reinforce
yeah because my queen was a little bit
overworked there
okay am I
I think it's still fine
like always have to watch out for these
potential tactics
at first it looks like the queen might
be overworked
but the Rook is useful in defending D5
in the event of trading on H3
I've never played squash
I've eaten squash
oh I like badminton too
I don't get the chance to play too often
though
okay so B6
you might threatening made in one so
yeah we do see a similar theme to the
previous game where I I was black I had
the feeling kind of Bishop and I use my
a pawn to create weaknesses
and White's basically doing the same
thing to my Queen side
but the difference okay there's a lot of
differences but one difference is we're
basically guaranteed to trade Bishops
unless white wants to keep the bishop in
sack The Exchange
which is not happening
and now
I guess I have to wonder about Knight G6
hmm
what to do
I don't want to waste time but
Knight G6 is a little bit annoying
I mean maybe what I'll do I'll just play
G5
so I got initiative like Knight G6 here
take take
only gets one move to try and disturb me
I'm not scared of H4 even though my G
Pawn is pinned I probably just move back
and we're reaching a position where
yeah the attack is coming hopefully very
quickly I have this move
anything better there's this move which
is interesting as well
and then
I don't think I can resist and the more
I'm looking at this the more I'm liking
it
so if Pawn takes I would check check and
take and mates
if that takes I just take back
and now I'm threatening this move
always play off three
I also have ideas of this move
yeah I wanted to do this and if King
takes then I have the fork
I really want to play Knight T4 but then
Queen A4
so let's start with this
okay now I have F3
and that will probably see
a pretty finish
and do I have a queen sack like the
oh wow it's almost working actually
there there
wow
I mean I could play F3 or I could start
with this move
this and then this
so unnecessary
oh
I don't think I can resist though
because it's such a beautiful line
I'm yeah let's imagine Queen A4
and now Queen H3
oh no my queen
and I take with check
King G4 and then
check here and then checkmate
let's go for it
there's some other lines too which
are maybe even more beautiful
oh no my queen
it was actually really beautiful if King
G2 I play F3
if King takes again it's mating on the G
file
King G2 F3 King G1 I played Knight E2
King H1 and then G2 checkmating with a
pawn
I don't even need my Rooks for that mate
I just need the pawn and
Knights basically
hey Eric oh thank you
I mean there's also Rook H2 but I think
this is
even more aesthetic
someone call an ambulance also thank you
for the 3000 bits way really appreciate
that
oh what a position
yeah I lost my queen but other pieces
are making up for it
a lot of ambulances need to be called
so yeah there's three legal moves if
King H1 I can
I can play G2 and then Knight E2 mate or
take and then 92.
any way to get the pawn mates
nah this is this will be a nice finish
G2
it's another case where I don't need my
Rooks
okay
that was a cool finish
I missed a free night
after Knight G3
a G3 was never played though
oh after Knight G6
oh queen of seven
oh fancy
I should have I should have considered
that
I was more focused on um not losing our
Rook
Queen F7
wait does Queen L7 not work
ah Queen F7 there's Queen B5 maybe it's
still fine for black
but it's not super clean
yeah the idea would be uh Knight takes
h8 and then I win the queen
which I completely missed
um and then going forward with what
happened the game
yeah F3 was
I mean everything is winning here F3 was
simplest but Knight T4 was pretty
ecstatic and then yeah engine shows the
horse mates
take and then take
okay Rook H2 is slightly more efficient
but
always play F3 with maiden maiden three
okay
is the tournament almost over
tournament might be almost over
go back
oh yeah turman's pairings are closed so
that was my final game of the tournament
a nice way to finish things
um I'm not finishing in the top three
but
I had some fun games
I hope people enjoyed that
got some nice instructive beautiful
rapid shots
um I'll probably make this as its own
YouTube video
maybe I got sidetracked a decent amount
but hopefully the YouTube viewers in the
future don't mind too much
hopefully the chats made up for it
um yeah if you're watching this in the
future
uh uh thanks for watching
don't forget to watch live on Twitch
don't forget to use merch
I'll probably still have the merch
coupon code
be available
uh coupon code birthday to save 15 at
least for the next big week
a week-long promotion